this week marks one year since a massive
explosion
rocked beirut the blast was caused by
more than 2
000 tons of ammonium nitrate that had
been improperly stored for years
it killed more than 200 people and
leveled a large area of lebanon's
capital
protesters furious about the lack of
answers and an economic collapse
clashed with security forces mta's
taeyab
has more
[Music]
they came in their thousands one year
after the world's largest non-nuclear
explosion
devastated their city what they want
is answers instead they were met with
tear gas
from a state which refuses to hold
itself or anyone else
accountable for the disaster
more than 2700 tons of ammonium nitrate
carelessly stored for six years exploded
at beirut's downtown
port devastating the city and lives
this should have been the happiest day
of isra sablani's life
but instead became a living nightmare
people when called me the famous bride
or
bride of beirut i remember
the bad moments at least 216 people were
killed
more than 6500 injured and entire
neighborhoods were left looking like
war zones it's been a year of healing
of a lot of trauma sema jalani is a
humanitarian aid doctor originally from
texas
who was living near the port she's seen
here consoling her young daughter
iman in an ambulance just moments after
the blast
my daughter had glass embedded in her
hands
and then also has scars on her
left hand and left leg we've had to do
serious work on ourselves
and and with her certainly with
counseling
and other techniques to try and just get
through
day by day a year later and the damage
port stands as a bitter reminder of what
happened
and what hasn't happened since lebanon's
political leaders continue to protect
their own
by obstructing the courts and blocking
any other meaningful investigations
into the blast
this is a country which is now a rapidly
failing state
an economic crisis has seen 90 percent
of the currency lose its value
fuel lines stretch for miles and
according to the u.n
30 percent of children now go hungry we
tend to think that these things are
caused by evil
but we never really took into account
the tragedy that could
ensue because of laziness complacency
and corruption
of a government corruption and a growing
sense of hopelessness
as every new crisis reveals and even
deeper misery
for cbs this morning i'm empty ostaya